speaking of secreto's uh there was a big
Secreto that you revealed to me when we
were playing basketball
oh yeah Trey Wasabi Joe is trans Oda
you shall see info nobody told me about
it
[Laughter]
secretos
let's see
see yo D gum
[Music]
ah see Isabella is also
see it's scary
or
[Music]
is
sedimentia
foreign
I really didn't know that he was super
religious at all I thought that you know
he has Jesus on the wall and you know oh
it's it's normal but I didn't know the
gravity of the situation that there was
literally like lists of reason why he
may not accept me because the only
negative comments that I get online are
either from trolls or religious people
saying I'm a sinner I'm gonna burn in
hell I have to repent before God strikes
me down so this is it's pretty
terrifying because it might influence
how he might perceive me after he finds
out that I'm trans
um
see
okay
foreign
[Music]
thank you